there's no easy explanation why generic
drugs which cost pennies to make are
sold with a markup of more than one
thousand percent one of the prime
suspects is pharmacy benefits managers
the middlemen who negotiate with drug
manufacturers and pharmacies on behalf
of insurance companies but everyone
involved seems to take a cut along the
way with a convoluted mix of inflated
prices secret rebates and discounts
mark cuban who's worth an estimated 4.5
billion dollars has had enough it's
ridiculous what the pricing for generic
drugs is cuban said and just like that
cuban is taking on these absurd markups
opening an online pharmacy where
patients can buy generic drugs with low
and transparent prices the idea for the
mark cuban cost plus drugs company grew
out of one of the most notorious pricing
scandals of the last decade as ceo of
touring pharmaceuticals martin shkreli
raised the price of the decades-old
anti-parasitic daraprim from 13.50 a
tablet to 750
that whole fiasco compounded by
skyrocketing costs of generic drugs led
one physician dr alexander oshminski to
cold email mark cuban with an idea for a
low-cost generic drug company cuban is
best known as a shark and owner of the
mavericks but he's also a passionate
investor in the healthcare space also
disgusted with the absurdly high markup
of drugs and lack of transparency cuban
was intrigued by the email they quickly
and quietly started working together
last january to hash out the idea it
would feature dr oshmiyansky at the helm
as ceo and cuban investing an
undisclosed amount of money and shaping
the strategic direction of the company
the mission to produce low-cost versions
of high-cost generic drugs the business
plan supply chain transparency they
purchased drugs directly from
manufacturers at a 15 markup and a three
dollar pharmacist fee and bypass the
middlemen to lower the price of more
than 100 medications the mark cuban cost
plus drugs company doesn't accept
insurance and it seems like a no-brainer
for people who are uninsured or on a
high deductible health care plan but the
fact of the matter is that even someone
who has decent insurance might be
overpaying for some drugs this is the
same reason why the pharmacy coupon
company goodrx has become so popular
because it adds transparency into what
is an otherwise incredibly opaque system
a 30 count supply of the asthma
medication monte lucas the generic for
singulair retails for around 169 dollars
the cost plus price six dollars a thirty
count supply of blood pressure
medication losartan generic cozar
averages around forty dollars the cost
plus price four dollars and fifty cents
a thirty count supply of blood thinner
clopidogrel generic plavix averages
around sixty dollars the cost plus price
five dollars and seventy cents
the company has partnered with online
pharmacy true pill for mail order
delivery and it is currently building a
22 000 square foot facility in dallas
where it will manufacture its own
medicines
[Music]